you meanwhile the justice department is
appealing that federal ruling to
reinstate a masked mandate for travel
let's bring in transportation secretary
pete buda judge mr secretary thanks for
joining us thanks for having me on i
want to talk to you about supply chain
and what you're working on but i do want
to ask you about this covet thing are
you going to that white house
correspondents dinner this weekend i
think i will yeah so the fact that dr
fitacy is not going does that send a
signal does it say something i mean what
should people interpret from that well i
think as he said that's his personal
assessment of his personal risk and i
think we are moving into a phase where
that's where a lot of the decision
making is going to lie right we're
seeing of course there are ups and downs
and maybe there will be more but
generally we've seen a move where you've
got fewer and fewer general requirements
for everybody and more and more it's on
you as an individual as a shopper as a
traveler
just when i introduced you i was talking
about the justice department appealing
that ruling to keep the mask mandate for
public transportation right up your
alley yeah i mean don't you think voters
will look at that and hold the biden
administration or democrats
kind of responsible for something that
they really don't want well the main
consideration there isn't the politics
of it it's making sure there's clarity
on the public health authority that the
cdc has in other words that would be
important to pursue even if they're not
going to use it right if even if they
determine
or they're talking about trains planes
buses that the mandate's no longer
needed and as you recall it was actually
set to expire within a few days of right
now anyway i know but just let me see if
you're sitting at home you just told me
you're going to the white house
correspondents dinner the president's
going to the white house correspondents
dinner you're not mandated to wear a
mask there but the administration at the
same time is fighting a lawsuit to
mandate people on planes trains and
audible or
trains and buses
to
wear masks so like if you're sitting at
home there's a disconnect here well i
think most of us understand the
difference between a hotel ballroom and
an airplane and again a lot of this is
about what authorities the cdc has so
even if they don't think we need it at
all they'd still want to make sure that
we get clarity in court on the
legalities of it but look as a practical
matter and i know this is confusing if
you're getting on an airplane it's your
call it's up to you and i think the most
important thing right now is that
everybody's treated with respect those
who choose to wear a mask and those who
choose not to well it's up to you if the
administration loses the appeal could be
either way right because if it expires
then uh even if the cdc has the
authority they might not want to use it
the legal side is about clarifying the
public health law in this country the
practical side is travelers want to know
what to expect when they're getting on a
plane getting on a bus getting on the
subway moving on
what has in your mind the administration
done to fight inflation well a whole lot
and i'll mention a few areas one what i
work on a lot of course around supply
chains one of many many things that's
pushing prices upward is shipping costs
and anything we can do to smooth out any
inefficiencies in the system is going to
help that's why we've been working both
on long-term infrastructure investments
and short-term improvements that are
going to make a difference but
let's also acknowledge that there are a
lot of things that can happen on the
policy side that would reduce costs for
americans in addition to what we're
working on the supply chain or other
pieces of it for example
the president has supported a move to
lower the cost of insulin house passed a
bill a few republicans even crossed over
to vote with democrats on this to cap
the cost of insulin at 35
and that's something i think most
americans would agree at least for those
families that are counting on insulin is
the sort of thing that takes the
pressure off when you're seeing high
prices putting pressure on other parts
of the family budget look there are some
parts of the economy that are more
responsive than others to policy choices
right but we know right now we could act
to lower the cost of prescription drugs
lower the cost of things like insulin
lower the cost of child care that's a
long-standing policy goal of ours and
again what i'm working on is things that
can help lower the cost of shipping with
federal spending though you know
fedex owner
founder ceo fred smith recently said if
i'm getting government check there's
less incentive to go into the warehouse
had we passed build back better that
bill that biden wanted my guess is that
we would be varmar germany right now
we'd have 25 percent inflation rather
than 9 or 10 and i asked about about
that when he was on the show this week
take a listen
secretary summers basically forewarned
of this in
february of 2021 instant
reduction of demand and then the
stimulus
payments created demand for goods and
then the third stimulus payment about a
year ago created a significant labor
shortage
and all of those went together to create
the situation we have today
so his point is is that the solution by
sent spending more money and now there's
this talk about
wiping out student loan debt
doesn't really affect inflation
well look the decisions that were made
to rescue the american economy
i think are rightly credited with why we
have low unemployment today and why more
americans have more money in our pockets
and yes that means americans are buying
a lot that creates a lot of demand and
when supply can't keep up that is an
inflationary pressure but it's
interesting that germany was mentioned
right so in modern-day germany in
modern-day europe you're seeing the same
inflationary pressures that we're seeing
in the united states this is largely a
global phenomenon we're seeing the same
thing with food prices and you know most
nobel prize winning economists who
evaluated the president's fiscal
policies believed they would actually
serve to ease inflationary pressures
everybody's entitled to their opinion
but the bottom line is we're working
against inflation with everything that
we've got
i want to ask you just quickly and this
isn't up your alley but dhs secretary my
organ said today that the blind
administration has quote effectively
managed the border crisis
do you believe that i think the the men
and women of
of the department of homeland security
and across the administration have done
remarkable work under extremely
challenging circumstances we also
recognize that those challenges continue
uh they may change they may grow
especially as you see pandemic related
restrictions uh shift like the
conversation around title 42 i'm not up
on all of the specifics and i don't want
to go down that road but he said in
private in august that he told the
border patrol that agents that the
situation was unsustainable and you have
to watch as a transportation issue uh
what's coming across the border and
where those folks are going no question
that's why we've been calling for
immigration reform for years look we've
got a broken system and the truth is
only congress can fix it for good uh i i
as a transportation secretary and as an
american citizen would love to see that
happen we really appreciate you coming
on and um i i do want to ask you about
this did you see this washington post
thing with the top 10 democratic
presidential candidates for 2024. last
thing on my mind right now is uh
presidential all right but you're number
two ahead of vice president harris it
says transportation secretary moves
ahead of harris and would enter 2024
with more heft as a cabinet secretary to
the extent people don't want biden or
harris he's next in line just in terms
of sheer plausibility
think about it at all no what i'm
thinking about is how to make sure that
we deliver half a trillion dollars worth
of value out of the funding that has
been entrusted to us by congress and
that the president has asked me to
ensure we get the transportation part of
it's right that is more than enough to
occupy more than 100 of my attention and
capacity and that's where my energy is
going families good they're real good
thanks for asking eight months and
counting and uh we're not sleeping much
but we're sleeping more than we used to
all right well have a great weekend we
appreciate your time hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else